Hey, girls. Janice,
is that really you?
Wow, you look amazing.
You must have had 75 different
expensive surgeries over the course of many years
to get a great look like that.
Nope, I just called Dr. Ron
and Cut 2 The Chase.
Aren't you tired
of plastic surgeons
who tell you to slow down or
think about what you're doing,
forcing you to undergo one
surgery after another
till you get the look you want?
Who has
the time or money for that?
At Cut 2 The Chase,
we do it all
in just one affordable,
apocalyptic procedure.
Would you like to look
like a human-cat hybrid
who eats bees?
Of course you would.
You have
crippling body dysmorphia,
and no one can talk
sense into you.
(woman lisping)
I used to hate people
knowing if I was happy or sad.
Now my face and labia
look the same.
Thanks, Dr. Ron.
My college-aged daughter
is really cute,
and that was threatening to me.
But now, my face is the one
threatening her
and all children.
Thanks,
Dr. Ron.
When I was a human,
I hated it.
Now I poop in sand.
Thanks, Dr. Ron.
(meows)
With my patented
Hail Mary technique,
I can perform five divorces'
worth of surgery
in one easy procedure.
Hmm.
Don't you owe it to yourself
to look like you fell into
a tank of chemicals
while fighting Batman?
Come to Cut 2 The Chase and get
your first and last procedure.
Cut 2 The Chase.
Because
you're (bleep) shattered.